what a time to be alive
i was in my underwear eating breakfast
at you know 1 p.m today you forget that
that this is the kind of fandom that
attracts
these people
i'm a great drinking buddy i've gotten
more than one movie just offered like
drinking at a bar
i just want to do the roles that you
know that satisfy me
and if and if that also appeases you
know the audience then then we're
we're in it together
[Music]
yeah at 35 miles is having a moment
maybe it's the stash or that pilot's
swag but his blink and you missed it
shirtless scene and top gun maverick has
the internet
i showed up as
in shape as i could i've never had more
oil
on me
running mile's biggest fan club wife
kelly who has no shame posting thirst
traps of her husband which are now
dubbed teller talk
i don't have you know
instagram or tick tock or anything but i
know my i know my wife i'll just see her
on her phone and then she'll start
cracking up i've never really
experienced something like this in my
life
some top gun secrets miles didn't know
the cameras were rolling when he did the
now iconic shimmy and he really played
the piano in this nod to the original
goodness gracious
it's a pretty tricky song but luckily i
played piano when i was younger so i
just had to dust it off a little bit
tom cruise put miles in the cast through
an intense aviation boot camp and we
were on the carrier the uss theater
roosevelt we were on that thing for two
weeks sleeping in a bunk probably you
know
30 feet below where they're launching
jets so the whole bunk is you know it's
just like
as for the mustache it was mile's idea
tom was on board but kelly was not i
felt different people looked at me
different and i kind of felt like a
cowboy or something did you oh yeah man
started walking just you know more
confident it was great
tom i don't think even had any idea and
then when we did our first camera test
together he hadn't seen me for a while
and so i had it for then and he was
really excited about it she wanted me to
shave it that's why that's why it's
never made a comeback
[Music]
miles met the model at a party in 2013.
that's the couple in taylor swift's
music video i bet you think about me
the pair said i do in hawaii in 2019
tay sent them flowers and the newlyweds
slow dance to the og top gun theme
[Music]
before miles got down on the dance
floor honestly i i'm a phenomenal dancer
yeah if i wasn't an actor i'd probably
go into dancing professionally
[Applause]
first play i ever did in high school was
footloose so to get to come back to the
part of willard
and you know show my stuff once more put
on the cowboy boots again it was an
incredible experience
when we first met a 24-year-old miles in
2011 he was in the remake of footloose
and told us this it's my secret weapon
and i actually you know it's hard to act
like you can't dance when you know that
you can
[Music]
miles is flying high now and you can bet
he's grateful when he was 20 years old
he was almost killed in a car crash
my buddy lost control my car going 80
miles per hour and we flipped eight
times i got ejected out the window and
car landed i was just laying like 50
feet from the car unconscious covered in
blood
bloody thaws dead
it took years of laser treatments to
remove some of the scars on his face at
first it was one of those things where
you know i'd go meet a casting director
and they would tell my agent you know
miles is a good actor but it doesn't
make sense for the character to have
scars and now it's like you know they
put scars on younger versions of me in
movies and so it's really kind of come
full circle
i'm sorry
oh i know after college miles landed his
first major movie role alongside nicole
kidman in the 2010 film rabbit hole he
earned just five thousand dollars when i
kind of was first getting roles did i
think that you had to look like an
abercrombie and fitch model apparently
to get a lead yeah i did think that and
i knew that wasn't my you know that
wasn't my forte if that's how hollywood
worked then then i would have a
difficult time getting the lead role
these are drummer thumbs by the way
that's what my mom told me that when i
first started drumming she's like oh
yeah those are your grandfather's
drumming thumbs i'm like
no they're not they're just fat thumbs
that i'm using to drunk
miles actually played the drums and
gained critical acclaim in 2014's
oscar-winning film whiplash his paycheck
eight thousand dollars
and did you know miles was actually
supposed to play ryan gosling's role in
la la land but says he was later told he
was no longer creatively right for the
project
this was like the most physical role
that i had done i was actively you know
kind of looking for something that was a
little more you know juiced up a little
more pumped up from the divergent series
to fantastic four miles proved his medal
as an action star in 2016 he dropped 20
pounds and had six percent body fat to
play a boxer in the true story bleed for
this 140 pounds even
it was a long day that last fight scene
was like 16 hours and they brought in
all these pizzas and somebody handed me
a pizza i could have cried yeah like i
woke up the next morning with the pizza
box next to me in bed
sergeant shuman
[Music]
is there something in you that connects
to these type of movies to celebrate our
heroes i grew up in a pretty small town
a lot of my boys are military and yeah i
don't think there's enough of these
films being made and with these two
stories i just really felt for the guys
i was playing some other things you may
not know about miles he actually plays
four instruments total piano drums
guitar and saxophone he once sang and
danced on stage with keith urban
[Music]
and he's very sarcastic my biceps would
be taking up the whole room
there's a lot of hot guys in this movie
i heard miles tellers in this movie
apparently he's really hot i think it's
all downhill from here
still when it comes to the two favorite
ladies in his life his mom and his wife
miles is seriously devoted my mom is a
wonderfully strong powerful intelligent
you know smart beautiful woman and she
ran my household i love making movies
but my you know my personal life and my
time with kelly and you know my family
my friends those those are the moments i
really you know i really save her
i've been lucky she's she's always been
my support and my but yeah she's she's
happy when she gets me back for sure did
you bring your wife
did i not mention her and we'll edit
that and i started with my wife
of course i brought my wife she's my
forever plus one baby
[Music]
you